so mike a lot of people have been asking
me
how to be a sigma male now sigma male is
something that
i think vox day brought into popularity
along with people like owen benjamin
but this guy the alpha show
is uh not to be confused with the alf
show which was
far superior he was from melmac yeah he
ate cats
so uh which is weird because they had a
cat and he never ate the cat
what can you imagine in that kid's show
that should have been the pilot if
[ __ ] in that kid's show of alf was
actually eating the housekeeper
they kid the pilot should have been the
kids come down
first day offs living there and the
living room looks like um
looks like remember remember when johnny
depp
was in nightmare on elm street it looks
like johnny depp's bed
like it's just a big old [ __ ] balloon
of blood
because he just carved the cat up and
ate it and then the whole episode is
just the kids screaming
this is my favorite alf video this is
actually this is from
the outtakes actor yeah
oh boy oh boy no boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy
yeah wait we don't need to hear this guy
but alfie come on man
alf based out huh
mel max had their own jim crow laws okay
anyway based in alpha pills
being a sigma male that's important to
most people
it's a real like roundabout way of
calling yourself a guy but okay
so i want to tell you about the alpha
show this guy shows you how to become a
sigma male and he
not only that he has courses he's
another one that sells courses of course
they all do
okay so you want to check it out sure
and mind you he made this himself he
didn't pay some indian and fire to do
this okay
how to become a sigma male the rarest
type of them all
hello guys welcome back to alpha show a
channel that will completely change your
life from negative to positive
and make you the person that you always
wanted to be so
and if you don't know now you know
you know very oh i thought you were just
very well
where alf's from because i went from
negative to positive
and it's all right sorry alpha
after this video you will know where you
fall in the spectrum of male
personalities
[Laughter]
if you're not already a sigma male this
video will show you practical steps to
becoming one you writing this down
no okay not at all sigma males are a
rare breed of men and are arguably the
most appealing to the ladies
nice i i i
i hate this guy they are quite different
from the naturally dominant alpha males
and
they're usually subservient beta males
beta
beta beta beta you're really playing up
that british accent to get more money
aren't you you [ __ ]
limey prick they're lone wolves who do
not conform to the
social section what you're a
lone wolf yeah you know who else was a
lone wolf [ __ ] timothy mcveigh
yeah and you know what usually defeats
lone wolves packs of wolves
yes it's true bucky sigma men
can dominate others but would prefer not
to
that sounds like a cop no you thanks god
exactly you're right no no no
it's by the way
i could dominate everybody in this room
if i wanted to
mentally but it's my benevolence
that i choose not to so so sigma males
are basically mac from always sunny
yeah you know what why don't you count
your blessings that i've chosen
not to mentally enslave all of you
people with my superior intellect
how about that oh [ __ ] despite having
the credentials of a leader
they'll also not lobby for leadership
positions they are call and don't brag
and boast like the alpha males
nevertheless like making an entire
[ __ ] thing on how to teach men how to
be cool
i want to see this guy i need to know
what he looks like i need to know
everything about this guy
i'll see if i can find him for you i bet
he's a real chad
alpha show okay i'll play the video but
i'll find him for you their silence
should not be mistaken for weakness or
shyness
but before we start with this video i
just want to mention our new course
called
30 days to alpha that we have been
working on for almost
six months it is based on three
different 30-day challenges and
more very useful things that will
completely transform your life
ah just sign up for a simple all you got
to do sign up for this yeah also you
can't spell transform with an e at the
end you dumb [ __ ]
i proofread your stupid ass you know
what's funny about this guy mike
no videos with him showing himself of
course not
they're all videos like this of course
not because he's a [ __ ]
he's a mess he's a skinny little i
guarantee he's british
he's a skinny little [ __ ]
guy he's got jacked up teeth
and he looks like on like very very
pathetically british guaranteed
but yeah transform with an e at the end
very nice uh video
i'm gonna move over to this it's the
same guy it's the same alpha show
this one is his most viewed video how to
make a girl
horny instantly really guys welcome back
to level up a channel where i post
videos that this is a different guy
sounds different it's the same channel
but this sounds like a different guy
we'll take her life to the next level
after this video
you will know how to make any girl
whether she is your friend your
girlfriend or just a random girl from
your class
extreme how about this how to make a
woman come
step one let another guy [ __ ] her
because you guys ain't gonna get it done
sexually addicted to you just by sitting
next to him that's a realistic portrayal
of of women these guys are
no you really do prey on these like the
women he's using as a cover of a gta
game
it's really it's a gta load screen this
is
dude it's so it's so [ __ ]
predatory what these people do sitting
next to her
okay so let's get started with the tip
number one sit really close
when you are with this girl you are
sexually attracted to me
by the way that's awkwardly closed
right now if you go and approach a woman
that you've never met before
do not sit super close to them that is
not that is another one of those
make constant eye contact pieces of
advice that an artist is going to take
literally
no you are not too do you know why
you're not getting laid and do you know
why
you're you're an insult because you
can't
pick up this it's for the same reason
like you probably have a shitty job
and you probably have no friends because
you can't pick up subtle social cues
that's what it is like there will be a
time to move in close if a girl wants
you to move in close
but you do not go up to a girl in a
restaurant sit down and immediately go
okay like right now hi there i was uh
wondering maybe
it's like and then the body language is
hurting it's just they're going i'm
eating could you not and you're like
i've read in a thing that i'm supposed
to get
i'm gonna call the police please don't
do that excuse to sit really close to
her pull out your tablet and show off a
cool new app or read out
long interesting articles oh my god this
guy
is he serious this is the same thing as
the alpha show but i think this has like
different dudes
this is a parody it's hilarious like
this is actually if
this was a parody i would be dying like
i feel like that's actually very funny
from a magazine she likes just start the
babbling about things that you have on
your laptop
and start saying them very loudly in her
face like that's
terrible advice first comment with a
1000 upvotes video should be titled how
to get arrested
arrested
as you sit next to her make sure you are
sitting in a tight spot so your arms are
touching each other
and even if there's a lot of what right
you've never sat next to a stranger and
made sure that your arms are touching
each other
well on an airplane but it wasn't my
choice yeah that's like usually when
you're like i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry yeah and
they're just as sorry yeah
i know that's terrible squeeze close to
her
and immediately imagine if you walk into
a room where there's only one girl
sitting at a bunch of empty seats and
you sit next to her
i would be panicking if i was that woman
okay so step one you would may
see go to the lunchroom do you see a
lovely young lady
she is sitting there enjoying a nice
meal and enjoying a moment of peace
and solitude what you will do is plea
you will walk up to her
and go hey uh do you know what the time
is and as they look at their watch
you will place your penis on their lunch
tray
have you tried this special you will say
try going into public swimming pools
like a community pool
and then king the women but you will be
in a pool so you will have some sort of
plausible deniability
this just turns into a sex pest and how
to muscle
if they are in jewelry grab it violently
angle what is that a rolex
oh [ __ ] remember when you are watching
the women through their windows
uh while they are changing remember that
when it is nighttime and their lights
are on they cannot see outside
what's a documentary porkies
[Laughter]
she focused the table or book in your
hands
so she's too distracted to slide her
butt away by the way
you imagine this guy trying to get laid
in america and being like
oh i see you are enjoying a book
what is your favorite book i think i
found the guy
i swear to god man it is like a roll of
the dice with accents
because you because like literally you
could sit down next to a girl and go
oh i am seeing that you are enjoying a
book
and girls will be like get away from me
but if you could be like an ugly guy but
sound like jeremy clarkson and sit down
and just speaking about it
oh good afternoon uh i was wondering if
you have the time
and they're like thank you and thank you
and then just go read your book and like
well wait a minute what's your name well
i've somebody fought send me the video
of this guy not the other guy this guy
so if he is kind of a chad
that's a chat
that's pretty pretty good looking guys
all right guys i'm gonna help you guys
out and you know what you don't even
have to be a part of my pro
my paid program free advice
if you're having trouble with the ladies
right step one
buy some weed i don't care if you smoke
weed or not no just have some i'm gonna
go buy something
step two buy have some food and some
booze in your house
you gotta mix it up too you can't just
have liquor can't just have big i have a
little bit of wine for these broads too
and then you just you just throw enough
[ __ ] at the wall like like it's almost
like
in a sales job you throw out a bunch of
leads and every time you talk into a
chick
be like yeah some weed at the house if
you want to like chill out
smoke whatever and eventually you're
gonna hit something
you're gonna hit something so let me ask
you a question
so what i should do is i should sit like
this next time no you shouldn't i don't
even wanna baby
hey baby where are you from i don't even
want no you sitting this close to me
that's
i this is how much i'm sorry i just
thought that that's what you wanted but
i don't understand
that these people who have never
actually interacted with a human being
but they read a bunch of books on how to
interact with human beings
this is basically what academia is
academia is the same thing it's a bunch
of people that read a bunch of smarter
dudes books about things
and now they're telling you how to go
out into the real world and utilize the
stuff they read about in books
but they themselves have never actually
tried in the real world
it's it academia has now spread into
everything
including pickup artist stuff
like i guarantee you none of these guys
have ever put this stuff in practice
no of course it's stuff they read from
books by like roush v
and all these guys and they were like
now they're like oh i'll i'll tell you
how the world works kiddo
this is what women want and it's like
have you ever gone out and done that
well no but telling you man it works
make sure your arms touch each other's
because the soft grazing of both
your arms is crucial to ruse the sexual
tension
and turn her on numbered this guy means
a rouse i think a ruse yeah he's not
very good with his
book learning but like
again guys this is all really bad advice
just so you know you have to keep her
interested you'll raise her guard
she's already okay have you tried being
interesting
well i run this thing called the alpha
show he's obviously
conscious of that get her distracted
from the touches by having an
interesting conversation with her get
her attention by gossiping about
something you heard or reveal a little
secret you heard from a little birdie as
long as i love her sorry
just start talking about the jq with her
aggressively
aggressively talking about it i i love
the fact too
like they don't even realize what a
perfect analogy this
is which is as he's giving this bad
advice he's drawing pictures of girls
because like none of this would ever
work in a real life scenario
it's just like everything about their
perception
of women and socializing and everything
is just
so childlike and and manufactured and
fake
they just have like this fantasy in
their brain of like you will go up and
say
how do you do what the book are you
reading and then she will suck your dick
right there in the library
to excite her with something while
talking to wow so interesting
these are these are guys just like
academia again
people people that are like college
professors they're all too terrified to
go out into the world
and and live their lives and and try to
go succeed in business or in
in in the public sector or whatever so
they just tell
other people how they can succeed having
never succeeded themselves
and it's like these people just don't go
out they have no real world experience
so they're just they're telling you this
[ __ ] based on faith
even though they've never put any of it
into practice like this guy
would would absolutely see a girl and
pay
i guarantee this guy sees girls all-time
panics never speaks to them
but in his mind he's like all that stuff
works though and it's like you wouldn't
even go up to a girl and say hello
these guys are all full of [ __ ] i hate
these kite types of people and he kind
of so predatory kind of talks like the
foreigners and family
guy he does have a litre of beer
to her she's overlooked the fact that
both of you are almost attached to the
heat number three start talking flirty
to her
getting a girl horny is easiest when
both of you have to sit next to each
other for a while with no interruptions
it doesn't matter if you are this is
like middle school
level like getting her horny
you must get the girl horny like so wait
again this i thought this whole thing
was how to approach women right
so am i now approaching women while
they're having their lunch
and i'm immediately trying to get them
horny because that seems
a bit right doesn't that seem a bit of
she's going out
for coffee with a girl at a starbucks to
try to get her horny excuse me i must
ask
now we have been here for 13 minutes
precisely are you horny yet
no like i don't even like you i didn't
even want you to sit down
what are you doing here because
according to my calculations
it's precisely 13 minutes you should by
now be horny
as i have done three leg grazings and
i've made two offers to be nice to you
i'm just glad western echo's doing
something to be honest with you
it ain't tipping
a room or a library or even while
traveling in a train or a bus but no
matter where you are
just get her involved and things will go
smoothly all the way
oh 100 every time you see how to they're
like this is what i also hate about
these predatory things
they're getting you to pay for this
program or whatever
and he's making claims that like even
predatory people wouldn't make like do
this and it'll work
a hundred percent of the time it works
half the time
you remember wedding crashers when then
he got so bad into it that he started
becoming a funeral crasher and he was
trying to do this yes
that's what this crew reminds me of
along the conversation get flirty with
her districtly
compliment her about something to start
with be very subtle or she'll move away
from you tell her you like her eyeballs
what her eyeballs
yes it's like you know he's foreign so
he's trying
you have very gorgeous eyeballs what
i like how you have all your teeth make
sure you tell her
you have never that is a good starter
great i like the fabric on your shirt
you have really nice eyes
or some [ __ ] like that oh by the way
anyway because he's a chad like oh yeah
somebody oh
chad it's throw some [ __ ] at these
small little bird-brained women man
whatever just say like the fabric under
these dumbbells will do whatever you
want like now no now you're a [ __ ]
chad now i'm supposed to think it is
[ __ ] slaying demon oh yeah bro women
are [ __ ]
on bro they just they'll give you dome
if you compliment their shirt they're
such
[ __ ] little bird brains and you're
like what
you're like you don't sound like a guy
who's out there just killing
[ __ ] doesn't matter just flirt like you
you flirt and by the way
gentlemen if you're watching this heed
my advice right now if you ever
ever start talking to a girl and in the
first 10 minutes go i like the fabric on
your shirt
you're done we're pulling you out of the
game i'm putting you back on the bench
you take a year off at that point you're
taking a year off that is you're going
you're going back to the farm league
it's right with the pharmacy i'm just
picturing a coach going
i'm pulling him this is this is get them
out get them the [ __ ] out
i like the fabric in your shirt
what it really brings out the color of
your eyeballs what fabric is
cotton i guess it's cotton i'm assuming
maybe a poly cotton blend i have no idea
i think it's cheaper
i got it free at a concert what are you
doing
why are you sitting next to me
and this guy just goes full over the top
somebody
and then like somebody comes over who
works there and they're like i'm sorry
is this man bothering you
not at all actually but i would like to
order now the lady
will have the uh she will have the
broccoli cheddar soup i already
made you sat at my table you're going to
love this this is a delicacy
my boyfriend went to the bathroom panera
bread he's like
you're going to love this they like to
make it special for me when i come
i would like the broccoli cheddar soup
right but could you sprinkle a little
parmesan on top they make this special
for me i know the chef in the back
that's like a guy i hate him close it
sparkles
you are just a few lines that will get
harmed
make her blush without moving away from
you keep the conversation going casually
and drop you but it's very discreetly
mean excuse me then later
i have an erection yeah i know
perhaps you can jerk my penis under the
table
while i stare at your eyeballs
are you in this country legally i'm not
cover my crotch with your book
give me a hand job comments or flirty
lines now and then
and if you have already texted dirty all
flirted dirty
with her earlier bring a few of those
lines into the car
all right this guy's like 12 years old
right he has to be like
look i we we have to end this show maybe
we want to finish this tomorrow because
i kind of feel like we should finish
this at some point
because number four is touch our fingers
this is
disturbing yeah please let's come back
to this we're coming back to this
tomorrow
guys this we rarely do this but this is
the tease and we we needed more time
i didn't know it was going to be this
creepy so we need more time
we definitely need more time